and all right everybody welcome to
another google hangout super excited to
be here with you we are talking today
about building your dream team virtually
and I've got a special returning guest
to the channel give us an introduction
tell us all about yourself well my name
is one of them back on Norwegian
currently in London got three companies
prominently in the photography and
outsourcing industry got a best-selling
book called never work again and yeah we
we help entrepreneurs like yourself
start outsourcing had like figure out
all the scary stuff getting over all the
fears and all the worries that you might
have about outsourcing and also you know
sort of best practices because a lot of
people they hire they try outsourcing
and they get to the point and then a
quick however i'm here to tell you here
today that it is a unique way of doing
business and today you know in 2016 we
have access to a global talent pool of
people all over the world which we can
get at pretty decent prices if we
understand the sort of philosophy and
methodologies that you need to learn to
to be successful at i love the idea
because as entrepreneurs were everything
from the CEO to janitor in our business
typically like the solo entrepreneurs
and you're first starting and there's
it's hard because you have to do so much
stuff when you're first starting the
company and if you can focus on the CEO
time right the big picture stuff and
delegate away everything else a lot of
people don't know how to do that and i
think if you can then that gives the
opportunity to build something really
special really amazing so walk us
through for somebody who hasn't hired
Sam to remotely there's a lot of
concerns as how to know you know the
person is not going to cheat me you know
how do I what's the steps what do I go
through to make sure that my first tire
is going to be a good hire so what I
recommend to everybody that is in
business for themselves is to have a
assistant so your assistant will do a
lot of these tasks that use quite simply
can you come to the end of the day and
you go hey
man I haven't had time to do all this
stuff and I wonder why because I worked
really hard I got up early you know I
did my meditation or maybe he didn't
maybe just ran out the door and made
lots of phone calls but at the end of
day like oh I didn't have come from you
this I didn't have time to do that so it
really starts for just that one person
that just just one person and so for
instance today what I have my assistant
doing is contacting lots of different
meetups in London to see if you know i
can speak at their event and that's
something that of course i could have
done myself I could have spent you know
eight to ten hours a day you know
figuring out what the meetups are and
who to contact and then contacting them
but that's so basically it starts with
that one person cuz if you have that one
person let's say you can say oh I need a
website I need a this and I needed that
and if this person that can actually
delegate to them you can say okay the
kind of people that were looking for and
the place I want you to find them is
maybe elance okay can you go on elance
and contact 10 different people that
meet these criteria and then have an
interview with them and figure out if
that's the person we want to work with
so i use them as a lot as like frontline
workers so i will tell i will have a
meeting with them um maybe 30 minutes a
day and i'll make sure that their entire
day is booked up with tasks and they
understand the task and then i get them
working on it so it really starts with
that one person that's how i started and
then from that one person I said okay
now I need some more people I need some
more people as more people and from
there it grew so without sort of over
company over complicating things I would
start with just a general virtual
assistant that can take off you know
sort of managing your calendar I playing
a tennis league here in London and I've
got to set up like eight different
matches right and it's like okay I could
do that myself but why not just get her
to set up all my matches for me and that
saved me like maybe five hours just so
much back and forth and this and that
and and you do then
then blah blah blah and actually making
a payment for the court and booking the
cord and like five hours of my life you
know Steve Jobs on his deathbed said
time was my most precious resource I
can't get any more of it you can't go
anywhere in buy more time so that's why
that's why I getting that first employee
working for you is so important now when
you go through that process there's also
different options you can do like
craigslist you can do all no jobs for pH
you can go to up work which is more like
four for project-based workers but you
can find people there too you can use
companies like social is it still called
Cyril because I know they were bought by
another company but anyway you can go to
all these like different be a services
and what I think is the most important
thing is that you start thinking about
it because without the thought you're
not going to move on and do the action
so it's not really like outsource to the
Philippines or outsourced to the US and
outsourced to India it's okay it's not
really relevant I mean I've been
successful in outsourcing the
Philippines but the most important thing
is like the mindset so let me ask you a
question have you ever flown on on
virgin america have I flown and virgin I
don't think I have okay I'm gonna want
any virgin stuff I love Richard Branson
but I don't know that I'm a virgin
customer ok I might be ruining your
example here ok we can do the different
example um the founder of night shoes
for instance ok Phil Knight yeah the
light if you go to the store does he
does he help you buy sneakers no no Phil
Knight does not help me buy speakers
right right so why well because he's
consistently had it yet a vision of what
he wanted and then he understood that by
bringing people together in a dream team
that could help him make his dream come
alive that's why night is sold all over
the world and he's doing very well is
because he has a vision he spends his
time on the most important
income-generating strategies and then
he consistently brilliant brains
talented people to him and that's the
reason why you use Richard Branson as an
example because he's an incredibly
charismatic entrepreneur yeah I was
bloody I got his books but he wasn't
yeah yeah right he wasn't given the book
to me so yeah I would say Richard
Branson only has well he's got many
talents of like his main talent is that
he's got a very strong personality he
knows what he wants and he has this
ability of attracting the absolute best
people to him so when he started Virgin
Money in the UK he went to the the best
small bank in the UK and he then was
able to attract the talent from that
bank to start building his company so so
as an entrepreneur it is actually really
important that we have this magnetic
force within us that we attract the
talent because people want a vision
people want to be part of a bigger dream
so in terms of building a virtual dream
team there's obviously some challenges
because you're not necessarily in the
same office so the question then becomes
how can you interact with people how can
you build a deeper relationship how can
you transmit your passion through the
internets so that they are fired up and
the way to do that is to actually meet
up on a hangout just like this and just
see each other and interact like normal
human beings and get actually the whole
team together so let's say you're
working with like a web design or SEO
guy etc get them all on a hangout
together once a week like 30 minutes and
just like just have fun like Austin
about what they're doing like what other
things are going on in their life
because ultimately your businesses like
when you think about your business it's
like very very important but to them
they have other things that are also
important like their family and their
hobbies and so it's important that you
actually are generally interested in
them as human beings rather than just
you them as like somebody that you can
just don't work on and just like just
get this done there's a lot of people
fail at outsourcing you're not good i
think it's because of the disconnect
that
internet has on us so there are rather
than them as human beings were just like
oh just like you were a robot just do
what I say right I mean I think about my
history the first guy I hired was for
one hour a day to free up basically an
hour plus of my time of day to focus on
bigger stuff he was doing database entry
stuff so I could focus on bigger picture
tasks and now I've got 16 people on my
team only one of them is physically in
the same city as me everybody is other
places around the world and I think it's
never been easier to build a great team
in the fan to attract talent there's
some people asking questions that I
wanted to address Lorenzo's asking what
would you say about adding in turns to a
startup business haunt us the good thing
with interns is that they're very blue
sky thinkers because they haven't had an
employer yet oftentimes that's kind of
told them like this is how you do it and
this is how the world works so students
can are very creative and how they think
plus they were very passionate and
oftentimes you can get them very cheap
or for free because they want they need
the work experience and if you can can
harness your talent and then create a
cool working environment it's a
fantastic way to build a business yeah
so I've had interns in my business and I
ended up hiring some of them into
full-time roles the thing I think is you
need to need to get them a space it's
hard to have an intern come work out of
your house uh my guess may be doable
them what the programs that I connected
with where schools and you had to have
an office to be able to make that work
and you have to give them time so I
think I think it's harder to get an
intern to work at least to the school
system remotely from from their house it
would have to come in if you're going to
get a credit for the program so may not
be quite the topic of that we're doing
right now but building a virtual dream
team um but if you have a location and
you have schools close to you might be a
good option yeah I mean I you need to
ask yourself like what can you do dara
there is is possible to get cheap office
space so yep um there there's always
there's always too there's always a way
if
needed cheap office space to kind of
negotiate with somebody you know there's
a friend of mine in Oslo where they
rented a quite a big office but that the
building is going to be torn down mm-hmm
so they've actually like cancelled all
the leases so they're paying like
one-sixth of the normal price just
because they they want to tear down the
building within one to two years so he's
got this really cool office space next
nearly free for for a year or more until
they tell them to leave but I so see you
know there's always excuses and there's
always a way if you kind of look for a
way to make it happen you can always get
an office space and open government
schemes also will have like if you go to
start up and oftentimes government
schemes will have some kind of way of
you getting free office space for a
while like an incubator or governments
bunch of stuff so the stuff is out there
yeah to be creative yet to be creative I
mean the first office that I had I paid
nothing for it was that young and king
which is the one of the it's in the
heart of the financial district here in
Toronto super expensive office space and
I just helped I agreed to help them with
their marketing if they gave me a desk
so I focus on my business and help them
with theirs i ended up bringing five
people into their business that we're
helping me on mine until I just kind of
outgrew the space that I had with them
but I didn't pay any bread ever in like
an awesome downtown location so is an
entrepreneur you got to be creative um I
would like to know which I think I think
it's important to lay down the ground
rules because there is one part of us
where you know we only value what we pay
for but we only value yet we only value
what we get paid for or pay for so like
if you have like a free book or
something like that and like just the
percentage of people reading it is it's
quite low because it's free because then
you don't value is that much if you
actually pay for a book it's much more
likely that you will read it and the
more you pay the more likely it is you
will read it it's the same with coaching
programs it's the same with so we only
value what we pay for or get paid for
so the question that is because like so
how do you lay down the ground rules for
students so I think it's very important
to be clear and say like you have to be
here then and then they need that kind
of guidance so that from you as well
plus there's a lot of cool ways to add
value to students like you can include
them more in discussions you know you
can take them out for dinner you know
like do more social stuff introduce them
to people so you need to be if you have
somebody for free need to be adding
value in some kind of other way Adam is
asking who who are our favorite
entrepreneurs who's your favorite
entrepreneur ooh Andrew Carnegie oh okay
yeah and back minus minus back to that's
cool okay i minus AP Giannini other than
that founder of Bank of America okay he
gave he gave entrepreneur loans based on
a handshake and a look in their eye if
you imagine a banker yeah saying based
on the look in your eye and a handshake
i'm gonna give you this loan he funded
Walt Disney when everybody thought he
was his crazy lunatic young entrepreneur
so I love the like helping out the small
entrepreneur vibe that he'd give off and
and I think Beck Americans are such a
terrible job of telling his story and
most people never heard of him but I but
Andrew Carnegie why I mean obviously
great entrepreneur but what did you
learn from him I think well first of all
he you know he's from Scotland he
traveled to the US and a very young age
started working in a railroad company
sort of any good mentor in any very
early found mentor and he was just a
very sort of positive cheerful person
you know I think he one of his famous
quotes is a positive attitude will get
you anywhere and I just really liked
that and I can kind of picture him as a
like a like a short period funny man
that just like was fun to be around but
at the same time he was also very good
in business like younger he built teams
and he built systems and I mean there
was a lot of sort of things going on
with the railroads and then rail strikes
and
he actually had military guarding his
factories and there's a lot of little
pins and outs there but he was good at
building teams and he actually had a
daily update that came to him because he
at some point he wanted to just go to
Scotland and play golf so he was
actually telegraphed every morning with
the numbers of the business and he would
like you would then reply based on
looking at the numbers because she
cannot manage what you don't measure
right so he would get the numbers and he
would he would Telegraph back and then
the business would keep on running but
he was like playing golf and trying out
lots of other ventures and he ain't
gonna understood the sort of sort of how
to have a freedom lifestyle as well as
being in business dossie build heat you
know the Napoleon Hill he sponsored
Napoleon Hill yep built all these
libraries and actually the most favorite
part that I like about him is that he
get his goal is to give away all his
wealth before he died and he said it was
more difficult to give away his wealth
than it was making it interesting I love
is a great story every team richest man
in the world when he sold his business
so it's a good you know he did a lot of
good too okay brent is asking Juve
advice or someone who left their job in
October I know how to run a music and
video recording also photography so you
left his job once to start a business
advice and getting started and then I
guess in the context of building a team
to virtual what what would you what
advice would you give to Brent you need
to find out what people's problems are
and then solve it so it's really about
so when you start a business you can
like you can push a rock uphill or you
could push a rock downhill and a lot of
people start a business pushing a break
of putting up pushing a rock up hill
which is like you can make it happen but
it's going to be a lot more work because
maybe you're inventing something that
the world's not quite ready for you yet
like 3d printing is like a lot of people
are talking about it but is it really
there yet maybe not it's in some
industries but not maybe in the
industry that you want to innovate it in
so by looking at people that actually
have a problem that actually want to buy
then in solving that then you're sort of
it so much easier pushing something
downhill and because business is
complicated enough in itself then you're
gonna have to try to go out there and
convince people that they actually won't
need to buy something rather than going
to people that want to buy something and
then giving it to them yeah all right I
think that's so just listening to like
people's problems and I think also
internalizing that it's like when you
start a business it's not about you it's
about people it's about people with the
problem that you need to help solve
their problem too i mean just add to
that i would try to find the one thing
that i could be great at the one thing
that you could be amazing at and deliver
amazing value to your client side and
then it's you need to find that try to
spend as much as your time as possible
doing that in the early days when it's
just you and you have no money then
you're putting your hustle and your
energy and your ideas and your time into
making it great but then as you start to
get a little bit of money coming in
you'll find that you're doing too many
tasks and you don't have enough time to
be that CEO and that's where bringing on
the team helps right bringing on a
personal assistant or bringing on
somebody to do some marketing for you or
database or website you know if you're
not if you're not the greatest website
designer in the world then maybe you do
your first one just to get it up there
and have something but you know the best
use of your time on going is not to be
the website designer so you want to go
and get someone who's great at building
websites to help you so you can focus
more and more and more of your time
being that CEO where do you go for for
your team I mean I almost all my team is
on up work it was odesk became upward
elance merge with them so almost my
entire team is on up work what where do
you go for your team ok so the funny
thing is I started with one person so
I'm actually personally I've never
actually hired anyone through through he
lands or up work the reason why is
because
so I personally haven't hired them but
my team has gone there and found talent
and but I typically will outsource the
finding of people so where I started
where I found a person cuz I I have no
money like I hadn't no money i had like
only thing i was like two hundred fifty
dollars a month for one person right
that's like that was it so i started
with one person that i found on wasn't
craigslist but it was another filipino
sort of job place and i put out a ad i
got 30 people applying i sent them all
the test now this is really important so
before hiring people you want to test
them okay so i sent them an image
editing test where I've made a mistake
so if they just follow the instructions
and they weren't paying attention to
detail they wouldn't have spotted the
mistake yeah so about 25 people failed
the test which was like a secret test
which wasn't in there it wasn't in the
description because i won't needed
somebody that was probably was able to
solve problems by themselves because of
the time zone and all that plus it
showed dedication posix showed how
dedicated they were to getting the job
so what I did after that was actually I
hired all of them I had hired the five
people that manage to figure it out and
I just like sent them an incredibly
crazy deadline and I saw who followed
through and then then it was like three
people left and then I had the three
people work for me for a couple of weeks
and I chose one guy that was like always
online always helpful always you know
said asking me is there anything else I
can do so really really motivated really
really passionate about you know making
this work relationship happen and it
turned out to be my business partner now
I'm on my company's called call Ramon
pancito and he was actually sitting in
an internet cafe where it hath bins the
owner to install photoshop on that
computer so he could do the work for me
and he just had his second kid and he
was like
it was so close to getting kicked out on
the streets so he was like I just have
to get this job and now he lives in a
nice house a nice area of the car and
you know electricity and internet always
like Weston thing here here now has a
nice life because of that passion that
you were talking about because he was
passionate about making it happen I'm
just going back to the the thing or any
review almost your favorite entrepreneur
again AP AP Giannini AP Giannini fini ok
so he said you gave people based on on a
certain look in their eye that they were
passionate right yeah and i would say
i'm actually reading this book called a
talk like Ted mmhmm yeah pretty much
look it's because i'm applying to
different ted talks at the moment yeah
and it's a really really interesting
book and I find like you know you know
every time you pick up the book you know
there's at least one thing that's going
to be in a ha moment if it's if it's any
good like not all books so so the thing
there is like if you want to be a good
speaker like the number one thing is
that you are passionate about what
you're talking about right so when you
start a business and you are not
passionate about the business then it's
going to be so difficult for the guy
across the table to shake your hand and
say yes we have a deal because maybe you
have no track record but if you're
incredibly passionate just like Ramon
pansy through my business partner if you
show that and that comes through that's
when you get it given the chance because
passion is infectious you know so I'm
just really enjoying that book only read
it like a chapter but it's really good
there was another question that came up
before but what what our favorite books
are so so you're reading that now what
is your favorite book or recommended
book that you would give to
entrepreneurs I you have your book
sitting behind you there so there's
never never work again but what other
what book would you recommend
entrepreneurs I think I actually think
the compound effect I usually say the
slight edge or the compound effect but
what I really like about the compound
effect is
makes it makes little habits relevant
okay so um just like when you play
tennis if you want to win at tennis it's
not about saying I'm gonna win the game
like I'm going to I'm going to win this
set when you're starting out okay you
can't really think about that and you
can think about what happened with the
ball that you just played the only thing
you can think about is like this one
ball the ball that's coming now I'm
going to win this point and I'm going to
do everything that I can to win this one
ball and it's the same when you pick up
the telephone when you call somebody to
get a web design and job okay it's it's
like this I'm going to I'm going to do
everything in my power right now to make
this call the best call I've ever done
in my life and then you do the best you
can and then the next call you do that
again and if you give it give it
everything you got every single time you
do something then that's constantly
compounding because you're incrementally
then getting better but it's very
difficult for us to sort of see the
improvements that we're making because
from day to day we don't really see the
difference so if I smoked a cigarette
today and smokes a cigarette tomorrow
etc etc and I kept on doing that for 10
years that would be you know 3650
cigarettes something like that so you
know 3650 cigarettes does and will
impact your health but one thing it's
not going to matter but it makes it
relevant that you know having that
cigarette or not it's consistently
compounding so if I started saving if I
started saving a hundred dollars a week
from I was born I would have like
millions of dollars right now but i
didn't i didn't do that little habit
over time and I think it's really easy
to look at people that are like uber
successful now and go like wow how can
you how are you so successful at this
age like cuz I'm the same age and what
did you do that that I didn't do
oftentimes they just did like little
habits every single day and over time
they don't really really give me any
good at what they were doing so that I
really liked that book it's called the
compound effect
and who's it by it's jeff olson jeff
olson compound effect ok cool breakfast
is rose Jefferson wrote the slight edge
the compound effect is written by the
editor of success magazine check i
remember right now rich rich harden rich
harden is that it hmm let's say remember
it's me look it up come on pounding the
fact if you want to learn more cool well
i mean it's it's crazy how quickly half
an hour goes for people who want to
learn more about you and the stuff that
you've got going on what's the best way
what do you have coming up ok so we have
a webinar coming up next Thursday it
could be at eight o'clock london time
which is probably for you then I think
it's three o'clock the important thing
here is that like register for the
webinar because we will be sending out
the replay so whatever times on your end
will send out the replay but if you want
the replay you have to register and
what's the topic the topic is I'm
basically going to show you how i
generate money by being the middleman so
being the middleman is a concept where
you know I go out there I I make a deal
and then I own the contract but then
i'll have a supplier that delivers the
work and that's how I that's how I make
all the money that's how I you know I've
been traveling the world for the past
five years making money while I sleep
because I I understand the concept of
the middleman and very few people do and
when they start out in business so
basically if you're employed in a
company right now your employer is your
middle man and he's probably making more
money than you because he is the little
man so that's that's kind of like a no
money down freakin business blueprint
that anybody can start applying but a
lot of people will be saying oh it's
okay for you because you have money I
don't have money so how do you saw you
get going in business with no money well
you can broker deals you go to somebody
with a problem and you say I'll fix your
problem then you find somebody else that
can fix the problem you make the deal
you make a percentage and that's all you
have to do
I love it cool well I have the link to
your website in the description but if
you send me the link to the webinar i'll
include that too and somebody's just
mentioning that it's darren hardy do he
just mentioned this darren hardy who's
the success magazine sir thank you do he
appreciate that Erlin thank you so much
for the time send me that link i put in
the description and thank you guys so
much for watching have a great rest of
the day